STEPHEN CARPENTER:
I want to show you
a picture, an image that
I created collaboratively
this morning.
So as you see, this was
tagged Danbury, Connecticut.
So that's just down the road.
And since I posted it this
morning, six hours ago,
18 people have liked it.
They haven't told me
what they like about it,
but they've liked it.
And I added some context there.
My name, or my handle is
there-- @bscarpenterii--
"Double Water Fountains,"
Danbury, Connecticut, 2017.
Then there's some hashtags--
#doubletaking, #troublemaking.
And then I've tagged
some other folks
who I follow or follow me, who
I thought might be interested.
All three of them happen
to be connected to MIT.
So this image is, in many
ways, just a black and white
Instagram photograph that I
also posted to my Tumblr account
and I posted to my
Twitter account.
This is a practice
people do quite often.
But this is a photograph
that originated and continues
to exist within a conversation
for me, with an existing
photograph, specifically,
other similar photographs,
as well as it sits
within a conversation
with other people--
as you can see,
at least 18 people who
like it but haven't
commented on why they like it.
This photograph was originally
taken as a color photograph,
using this phone.
I set the setting from portrait
and landscape to square,
because we can do that now.
We have these options.
And then once the
photograph was taken,
I put it through a series
of filters in Instagram
to turn it into this black
and white photograph.
Now, as you can probably
notice, I most likely
didn't shoot this on my own,
unless I had a tripod and then
a timer that I set.
So one might assume that
someone else actually
took the photograph.
And that's what happened.
This is the most recent
photograph in a series--
I believe I'm at or beyond
100 of these in the past three
or four years--
in which, if I'm
in a public space
and I see a double
water fountain
and there's someone nearby,
I'll ask them-- excuse me.
Would you give me a hand?
I'm an artist.
And I take photographs of
double water fountains.
Would you mind taking
a picture of me?
I'm going to drink
out of the fountain.
And I'd like you to
take a picture of me.
Make sure both fountains and
my body are in the photograph,
please.
That's all the
instruction I give them.
There's no composition 101.
There's no depth
of field lesson.
And then they take a picture.
And I drink the water
during the entire time
they're setting up and moving
their body and in and out.
And sometimes it takes
a couple of seconds.
Sometimes it takes what
feels like four or five days.
You know, you've had
this experience, right?
And then what happens
when you ask someone
to take a photo of you using
your camera or your phone?
They turn around and
they show it to you.
We can do that with
digital photographs now.
How is that?
And I look at it, and say, oh.
Oh, that's quite nice.
And then if they have time, if
they're not rushing off-- oh,
I have to run--
well, would you mind looking
at another photograph?
And most of the
time they say, yeah.
I'll look at the
other photograph.
And it's that other
photograph that I show them
that inspired me to start
taking these photographs.
So the other photograph
I show them is this one.
This is also a black
and white photograph.
It was not taken
with a digital phone.
It was actually
taken with a camera
that uses this interesting
technology called film.
A lot of people who
use these machines
don't actually
know what film is.
And this photograph was taken
in 1950 by Elliot Erwitt.
It was taken in South Carolina.
And this photograph
shows a gentleman
wearing a hat, drinking out
of one of two water fountains.
The water fountains
each have labels.
And they, although, are situated
as double water fountains,
or side-by-side fountains,
they are, essentially,
constructed for different
audiences and different users.
And we might know that
because of the labels
that are above them.
This photograph, double
water fountains--
or, it's actually called
"Segregated Water Fountains"--
is one of a few that
Erwitt took in the '50s.
He used to take--
he was known as a
street photographer
at that time, when he was taking
photographs, and capturing just
some basic, typical scenes that
would happen in daily life.
So it's this photograph that
I had probably seen, or one
of them similar to it,
years and years ago.
I don't remember the
first time I saw it.
And you know how images come
in and out of your life,
or people come in and out,
or stories come in and out?
Well, this one did
the same thing.
But about 10 years
ago, 15 years ago,
maybe, when I started wearing
hats like this, in part because
I just thought they
looked pretty interesting
and they reminded me of
my grandfather, whose
first name is also my
father's first name--
it's also my first name, so
there's that connection there.
And as I looked
at this photograph
shortly after I started
wearing these hats,
I started to see these
photographs differently,
because as I looked more
closely at that photograph,
I started to see myself
in that photograph,
and wonder whether years
before I was even born--
I was born 15 years after
this photograph was taken.
But certainly, signs
like this and practices
that these signs encourage were
still in place when I was born.
But as I continued to look
at this photograph and others
like it, I would see
myself in it differently.
And I would wonder, would I--
what would I have felt like?
What would I have done?
What would it have been like
for me to be in that situation?
So I started to take--
in public places, it's not
uncommon to see double water
fountains.
In public places, it's not
uncommon to see other people.
In public places,
it's not uncommon
for me to have my phone,
which takes pictures.
So that combination
of components
inspired me, or has been the
motivating piece, and also
the materiality of
this series of works.
This is on a beach
in California.
I don't recall
where this one is.
Instagram remembers.
I don't have to remember.
This is in the State House in
South Carolina, three or four
months before the
Confederate flag
that was flying about 100
yards away from this spot
where you see me, three
or four months before it
was taken down a few years ago.
So my daughter, who is
now eight, but at the time
that this photograph was taken,
she was about three or four--
and because I think
I'm a pretty good dad,
I take her with me
to various places.
And public places have
double water fountains.
And she would
watch me ask people
to take my picture in front of
double water fountains, which
was all well and good,
because that's what papa does.
He's an artist.
And he does things
and takes images.
But one day, she asked me,
Papa, would you take my picture?
I said, sure.
I would be happy to.
But you have to take my picture.
[LAUGHTER]
And so we gain
perspectives on the world
through the eyes
of other people,
seeing what we see
through what they see.
But more than that being
an interesting photograph
of this three-year-old angle,
a few feet off the ground,
it was also a moment where I
realized that the next question
for her after, would
you take my picture,
was, Papa, why are you
taking these pictures?
So then I had to
have conversations
about the history
of this country,
and a particular story, an
ongoing story, an uncomfortably
challenging story in the
history of this country, a story
that we're still writing today.
I had to talk to my
daughter about race.
And so this project, the "Double
Water Fountains" project,
you can find on Tumblr.
Just look for @bscarpenterii,
and there it is.
I post these images quite often.
So I'm saying all this to
say, these photographs come
from my interest in
and my relationship
with the double water
fountain photograph,
or the segregated
photograph, by Elliot Erwitt.
This historical
photograph, for me,
sits in a conversation with
many other photographs like it,
but also within the
practices, the policies,
the cultural understandings that
allowed for segregated water
fountains and
segregation to exist.
LARRY SUSSKIND: If you
walk down the street
of Baltimore or Philadelphia--
and there's plenty of
confrontation this last year
in Philadelphia that a
lot of people would feel
is racially rooted.
And if you say, oh, we
should have more constructive
conversations between people.
They should learn how
to deal with conflict
that's in some way connected to
or racially defined or rooted.
And well, people don't
know how to do that.
They don't know how
to do that, to--
cross race.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Sure.
LARRY SUSSKIND: And
so you think it's
the picture that makes
the conversation possible?
It's a pretty harmless picture.
It's not an
inflammatory picture.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: No.
So the conversation begins well
before the photograph is taken.
The conversation begins well
before the Erwitt photograph
is presented.
The conversation begins
well before the conversation
about race or history or
wherever the direction is.
Right?
So your question
about, well, how do we
engage in these
conversations-- how
do we engage in
these conversations?
We start the conversations.
I don't know that--
I take it-- I'm concerned
that when I hear statements
or there's an assumption
that, oh, well,
it's a difficult conversation,
we can't talk about it,
I don't think that's
the case at all.
We can.
I think it's the starting.
And this is, I think, central
to part of your question
is, how do we start
those conversations?
I think we need to start it.
The mediator, which
is also what I
heard in what you
were saying, might be
the camera and the photograph.
It might not be
another individual.
The third thing I
would say is, and I
hope this came through with
my description and my earlier
responses, I'm not trying
to persuade anyone.
I'm not trying to make a case.
Or, in your example, where maybe
sensing someone's defensive,
I'm not trying to nail them to
the wall or prove them wrong,
but bring up other
examples that allow us
to continue the conversation.
It's about opening it
up rather than saying--
so for example, if someone
said, oh, well, we're
way past that, I'd
say, no, you're wrong.
Here's-- I wouldn't-- it's
not about, no, you're wrong.
It's, oh, well, what about this?
Or tell me about such and such.
So instead of being persuasive
to the point of arguing a point
to convert someone from one
perspective to the other,
while that might be,
at some level, a goal
for some folks
engaged in this work,
I think before one gets
there, becoming comfortable,
setting a comfortable
space for the conversation
needs to happen.
So it's not about persuasion.
It's about, let's open
up that space and talk
about the difficulties
within, and the complexities
in that conversation.
LARRY SUSSKIND: So for me,
there's something unusual
that I think is attributable
to the photograph, to the fact
that the photograph's
at the heart
of a conversation about race.
And there's both
an old photograph
and a new photograph.
And in some other realms,
particularly in the realm
of science, there
are difficulties
of people from different
disciplines talking
to each other.
And one theory about how to
overcome those difficulties
is to use something known
as a boundary object.
So it's not me and you and
our different disciplines.
It's, oh, here's a map.
And how do you read that map?
Oh, no.
I read that map differently.
What do you think that map said?
Oh, I think-- and I don't
have to talk directly
to a person from a
different discipline.
We can both be talking about
or through the boundary object.
And my question, and
the question in my mind
was, does a photograph,
in particular,
and a black and white
one, in particular,
an old versus a new
one, provide a means
to address, in this
case, a potentially
difficult conversation?
Now, I think who the
people are matters.
And I think your
non-defensive style
and your willingness to track
the conversation wherever
it goes probably has more
to do than anything else
with how the conversations
you have turn out.
But I'm trying to see if we
might deduce from your project
some kinds of insights
about the use of photographs
in particular, but
not only, to make
difficult conversations easier.
That's where I'm going
with my questions.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: So your
example of boundary object
is interesting,
because it makes me
think of a couple
of different things.
One, when talking
about works of art
in schools, or
even in galleries,
for a number of reasons
that we don't necessarily
need to get into at
this point, many folks
are interested in the formal
qualities of those works.
And those formal qualities are
fine-- formal meaning shape
and color and texture.
But as we start
to look and think
about those works
of art contextually,
place them into an
historical context,
a social, political
context, those works
are about those other
realms as much as they
are about the physicality,
moving it away
from the material, the physical
material into other kinds of--
what might move into new
materialisms in some way.
So I think there's a
bit of that going on,
where your example of the map,
it's not about the physical map
itself.
It's about the representation
and the signifying aspects.
Now, these photographs, the
black and white component,
the formal aspect,
moves it away from--
and this was intentional for
me, because the original dozen
or so that I took were in color.
And there was some
distance for me
between those color images
and the Erwitt photograph.
And it wasn't until I tinkered
with the first one in Instagram
and made it black and
white-- and I resisted it,
because I didn't want
it to be too literal.
You know?
There was a shift that happened.
The time element flattened.
And so putting oneself in--
there's something about a black
and white photograph that
it moves it away from
a contemporary sense of--
because the color gets removed.
Now, the other piece there is--
so you know, you want to have
an interview with someone.
So you say, OK, bring an object
that means something to you.
Or we'll talk about this map.
This photograph, we
produced together.
As a matter of fact, the
person I'm talking to,
they're the ones who
produced it, primarily.
They composed and took the shot.
So they have a degree of
ownership and connection
with it.
LARRY SUSSKIND: That's
very interesting.
That's a very interesting
way of reframing
why it might be
easier for them to use
the photo as a basis
for the conversation,
because they have part of the
ownership of having taken it.
STEPHEN CARPENTER:
Not only are they
part of the ownership
of having taken it,
but if you look closely
at the photograph,
you don't see them
in the photograph.
I'm in the photograph.
So anything they say about
it is separated from them.
But it gets difficult,
too, because the person
in the photograph is the
person standing next to them.
So while the photograph
allows for some separation
and objectification of that
individual, the very subject
at hand is right there.
So there's a complexity there.
But their contribution
to the creation
of that work and that
ownership, I think,
is key to this conversation.
LARRY SUSSKIND:
I've been trying,
since the first time I saw
this, to imagine if there
is a method in here to make it
easier for conversations that
have race at their root.
But I particularly mean
conversations about situations
where race is at
their root, and they
are about people
being unable to deal
with differences in any other
way except through violence.
And so I want to
make them harder,
more difficult conversations.
But I'm trying to imagine--
and hopefully, we can actually,
at some point, do this--
whether the same smoothing or
easing effect of the exercise
makes it possible to
have a conversation,
which, otherwise,
you couldn't have.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Yeah.
I think so.
A statement that
I'll use tomorrow
in the lecture and workshop,
but I'll use it right now.
I was in-- it was
about three years ago.
I was teaching an
undergraduate class
of students who were
preparing to be art teachers.
And we were talking about,
I said, what is this art?
What does art do?
Why are we studying art?
Why do you want to
be a teacher of art?
What is art's role in our lives?
You know, these really small,
insignificant questions.
No, it's a big,
important question.
And one of the students
said, you know,
art allows us to--
among the things
that it does-- but it allows us
to tell stories that we might
not be able to tell
otherwise, and we probably
can't tell otherwise.
And I thought, oh, yeah.
That makes sense.
LARRY SUSSKIND: It's
consistent with the theme
that I'm pursuing.
I mean, people are
terrible, if just
caught off-guard and with
no special training, trying
to deal with issues that
have race or ethnicity,
and many cases, gender, at
the heart of the difference
or the conflict.
And I'm just trying to think
of this notion of flattening
and overcoming history by
having the two black and whites
next to each other
in the same location.
And now, not everybody is
as charming as you are.
And so they would not
get the same response.
But maybe the
existence, and the fact
that they took the
new picture, which
I hadn't thought of until
you said it this afternoon,
is, you know, they
own some of this.
So now maybe it's
easier for them
to stay with the conversation.
Maybe adding an artist makes--
and doing these things--
makes it easier.
Also, you start out by
saying, I'm an artist
and I'm taking these pictures.
STEPHEN CARPENTER: That's right.
LARRY SUSSKIND:
You don't say, I'm
someone waiting on the
street corner to ambush you,
because I don't know
if I can trust you,
and you probably don't
think you can trust me.
None of that.
It's just, I'm an artist.
Will you take a picture
of me doing this?
And that's very disarming, in
every sense of that phrase.
And then maybe that's
the key to moving
toward a conversation
where nobody's anxieties
and prejudices go sky high
right at the beginning.
Now, I don't know how
long it would last,
once you tell them
what that side is,
if they didn't already know
it, in the model that I'm--
STEPHEN CARPENTER: Sure.
And they might
know it, especially
if they live in that
neighborhood or nearby, which
would then be quite
a rich conversation,
in unexpected ways, I
guess, for the artist
who is initiating their work.